in Russia the US ambassador has met with
a Michigan man accused of spying Russian
police detained Paul Whelan nearly a
week ago and he now faces espionage
charges Wieland's family says he's
innocent and they're worried about his
safety Jan Crawford is outside the
Russian embassy in Washington Jan good
morning
well good morning so the US ambassador
to Russia John Huntsman was finally able
to meet with Paul Whelan yesterday in a
Russian prison ambassador Huntsman also
talked to some members of Wieland's
family that's the first time it heard
anything about him since Friday that of
course is when Russian officers arrested
Whelan on charges of espionage now the
Russian media is reporting this morning
that he was picked up in his hotel room
he's accused of trying to recruit
Russians took on a spill state secrets
and give inside information but his
brother David has told CBS News that he
was actually in Moscow for a friend's
wedding and that he had been to Russia
several times before now according to
Stars and Stripes Whelan had given
wedding guests a tour of the Kremlin and
some of the museum's Friday morning but
of course he never made it to that
wedding on Friday night now Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo has delivered a pretty
stern message telling Russia that if
this detention is inappropriate the u.s.
is going to demand an immediate return
Anthony Jen thanks so much